I gotta tell you one last print story I
got so I was invited to perform during
all-star weekend yeah it was in
Minneapolis and you know Prince wants
you to perform at his club he had this
club I forget what the club's name was
so I go in there to meet Prince and his
like road manager these guys picked me
up so this has to be 95 maybe picked me
up they take me I was like where's
Prince and they said well he's not here
and I'm like [ __ ] that's the only reason
why I did the game right they said well
all right all right here we go
so they toured me all around Paisley
Park you know at that point that was
farmland right now it's like a suburb
but at that time there were cornfields
and he had bought this property and
built this studio and it was incredible
I mean right impart money to the oh yeah
so the guy tells me this story and he
said that one time they were on the road
and Prince calls him at 3:00 in the
morning
and he said that's not unusual because
Prince was known to go he would call in
and he'd say yeah 3:00 in the morning
so he said 3:00 in the morning and he
answers phone he says what's up in a
hotel on the road he says their
[ __ ] voice is coming from the
[ __ ] laws he's like
[ __ ] you better come to my room
so he goes he knocks on the door
Prince opens it up 3:00 in the morning
he has white satin pajamas white satin
do-rag perms makeup and white satin
high-heeled boots and he says dude
what's going on
I told you man there's [ __ ]
voices coming from the [ __ ]
walls and so he comes in the room he
says ok Prince what is going to the
[ __ ] listen so they're quiet and
they hear this voice coming from the
wall a female voice so he calls a hotel
security they call the police they do a
complete sweep they find this woman who
is in the crawlspace behind Prince's bed
with a flashlight and a Bible and she's
reading Bible Bible verse to try and
convert Prince oh my god for real it was
absolutely for real so he said as they
were dragging this
woman screaming aha prince is sitting at
the table with his legs crossed and he
says I told you [ __ ] a
[ __ ] voices coming from the
Wonder [ __ ] balls but y'all
[ __ ] didn't believe